it was a trip organized by the Ukrainian
police but many villagers turned up to
meet the visitors expressing not only
relief but also shock at how quickly the
occupying forces left for months they
were cut off from the world living in
fear says Olga ibanova these are tears
of relief after she witnessed the
chaotic Retreat of Russian soldiers
we found 16 of them hiding in a cellar
with nowhere to go others left with
stolen cars and bicycles that's how the
Russian retreat was
it was on September the 6th
they ran away they didn't leave they ran
away the officers fled first and left
the lower ranks behind the next day two
missiles hit the only School in the
village of verbka that's where they were
based says Nadia
they left behind uniforms and ammunition
she thinks they bombed it to destroy
evidence of their presence her daughter
used to study in this classroom
balaclia was the first significant win
for the ukrainians since they started
this counter-offensive at the beginning
of September and as we were driving here
we saw similar scenes of Destruction
along the road now this is very similar
to what we had witnessed north of cave
in places like Butcher and airplane when
the Russians pulled out earlier this
year
as we drive towards the city of balaclia
more scenes of a hasty withdrawal an
Army in disarray shelling from a farther
territory it had just abandoned
here the occupation Hub was the police
station up to eight people were held in
these windowless cells
one of them was counting the days long
days of beatings and torture in some
cases forensic experts say forces from
luhans one of the two self-proclaimed
pro-russian republics were also here
not far away war crimes investigators
are already at work two bodies are being
exhumed but they are so far no traces of
the mass killings seen in Butcher North
of Keith
Ukraine says it has reclaimed 300
communities home to about 150 000 people
but Russia still holds large parts of
the country the Hasty Retreat May signal
Ukraine struck first where the Russian
defenses were weakest
in northeastern Ukraine